You wear underwear under your bathing suit, yeah doesn't everybody
[gets hit]
AHHHH
OWWW
Ah
If it isn't another Groundhog Day type movie
[smashes alarm clock]
'Palm Springs' Hulu's latest original starring Andy Samberg and Cristin Milioti is actually pretty good
I mean, it's no masterpiece that is 'Happy Deathday 2'
"Stop Global Warming?"
[throws notebook]
[screams]
"You are gay"
In this video
We'll be taking a deep dive into 'Palm Springs' explaining its time loops and what exactly happened in that ending
But, before we get stuck in an infinite time loop, make sure to LIKE and Subscribe for more breakdowns, theories, and deep dives
Palm Springs is the story of Niles, a man forced to live the same day over and over again
Unlike movies like Groundhog Day which take time for the protagonist to get into their loop 'Palm Springs'
focuses on Niles who has already lived this day hundreds if not thousands of times
He's complacent, thinks life is meaningless and has given in that, this is his fate
"The only way to really live in this is to embrace the fact that nothing matters"
"I think your best bet is just to learn how to suffer existence"
Niles has to relive the wedding of his girlfriend's best friend's wedding over and over, a wedding which takes place November 9th
which coincidentally is the same day Albert Einstein received the Nobel Prize for his work on Theoretical Physics. For Niles
this is a day like any other.
He's completely memorized where everyone on the dance floor will be to try to woo Sarah, the bride's sister
and Sarah like Niles is extremely flawed. She believes love doesn't exist in that marriage is bullshit
"Nobody can stand the idea of being alone"
"So we
buy into this pageantry, celebrates it's...
bullshit
So, it makes sense that the man who thinks life is meaningless and the woman who believes love doesn't exist to get stuck in a
time loop together for all eternity. You see the night they're about to get it on, Niles is attacked by a man
we'll come to know as Roy, Roy is also stuck in the loop
In fact, it was Niles who brought Roy to the mysterious time-loop cave one night during a coke induced bender
Oh, yeah, there's this cave that has a portal in it that traps people in the time loop
The problem is there doesn't seem to be a way to end the loop
If you go into the portal you just wake up and start the day over again
But if you don't go into it, you'll wake up and start the day over anyway
There's no escape. Roy holds Niles responsible for getting trapped in this loop and often comes looking for him to torture
He believes marriage is a bottomless pit, but as we'll find out later
He lets go of his hatred towards Niles and embraces his life. Hopefully, Niles can learn that he can change too
"What happened to marriage being a bottomless pit of sorrow?"
"Things change you know..."
"Priorities change"
Over the course of the film, Niles and Sarah fall in love, go on adventures and just have fun with the card they have been dealt
We learned that Sarah had sex with her sister's fiance the day before the wedding. That pain of the terrible things
she's done eats away at her and she takes it out on Niles. In retaliation,
he tells her he had sex with her multiple times in previous loops before she got stuck
This is the classic romantic comedy structure
we're about
three-quarters of the way through the movie shit hits the fan and it looks like our couple might not make it through at all. Niles
wakes up after their fight and for weeks? months? years? We actually don't know how long because the loop keeps repeating
He can't find Sarah
She's gone on her own adventure to find a way to break the loop, spending most of her time reading about Quantum Physics
Eventually, she finds out that the loop has a brief 3.2-second window where one can propel themselves out using explosives, of course
And she knows this could work since she experiments on a goat who the next day is no longer in her loop
It didn't reappear. So, it must have gone someplace else
Sara tells Niles the good news, but he doesn't want to leave.
"Don't want to leave. There's a difference"
Oh, yeah, what's the difference?"
"I want to stay with you"
She wants to go.
He wants to stay
And, Ultimately, she decides to go without him, spending her final night giving a heartfelt speech to her sister at her wedding
But, there's one scene that really confused me and I'm wondering if any of you who watched it caught it.
Get ready to put on your tinfoil hat
After Sarah gives her speech
grandmother comes up to her and tells her how great it was. But, watch this and pay close attention to Sarah's reaction
"Well, I suppose now that you'll be going soon"
[silence]
"Good luck".
I suppose now that you'll be going soon. How does Nana know here that she's leaving tonight? Is she referring to her leaving the party?
I know this is gonna sound bonkers
but, it almost made me think that Nana is part of the loop too, after all in this loop
she gets to live over and over again with the ones she loves. If she were to go back
Well, she's old and who knows how much time she has left.  Am I crazy?
Let me know what you think in the comments below
At the same time, Niles is moping at the bar lamenting losing the love of his life when he's given some great advice from Darla
"Whatever you're after, it ain't here".
He rushes to Sarah and professes his love
"I'd rather die with you"
"than live in this world without you"
Niles has gone from thinking life is meaningless to thinking life is meaningless without
her. Sarah has gone from believing love as a fairy tale to knowing that true love can exist
"In case I don't see you again..."
"...I love you too"
They head into the portal and detonate the explosives when we next find them floating in a pool together
and there's a brief moment of wondering whether or not their plan worked. Niles says
he should go pick up his dog now considering the plan did indeed work as the owners of the home they've crashed arrived
It's November 10th and the day has gone forward and they've successfully broken from the loop
but, more importantly, they've broken their preconceived notions of love and
existence. Through their love, they've realized life is worth living. The camera pants upward to reveal in the distance a pack of brontosauruses
Brontosauri?
A nod back to the night they were high on mushrooms
I imagine some people may interpret this as them still in some weird alternate reality, but I personally wouldn't go that far
It's just a fun way to end the movie. However, there is one final scene shortly after the credits, which lets us know
What happened to Roy?
He is still in the loop
And, at the wedding goes to Niles telling him that Sarah's theory about getting out of the loop is crazy
But, it just might work Niles. However, has no idea who he is
Thereby letting Roy know that Sarah's plan worked and that he and Sarah made it out of the loop.
Overall, I gotta say I
enjoyed 'Palm Springs'.  Andy Samberg and Cristin Milioti have great chemistry, and it was a fun twist on a gimmick that has been overdone
Thanks everyone for watching make sure to LIKE and subscribe and leave a comment below
For more bat takes you can follow me on twitter at ThinkStoryYT
Until next time remember, Daddy loves you very much
[Outro Music]